hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute am
montag montag sind scheiße mir wurde
sehr auf das spiel zugesendet bei
standing der und ach guck mal wie können
uns hier sogar können wir können wir
nicht wenn ich ach ich kann mich bewegen
wir sind diese schwarze person und ich
laufe einfach auf diese person bei den
chips
es geht wohl irgendwie darum dass ich
eine freundin habe und total in sie
verliebten aber die entwickelt sich dann
irgendwie einen zombie und wir klicken
einfach mal auf play game und wenn ich
jetzt hier actron service die wohl
schönste freiluftkino sorgen also wenn
ihr zu ihren lauf ach dann bin ich sogar
tot ich habe die musik ausgemacht meine
musik hinter gepackt deswegen weiß ich
jetzt nicht ob weil ich habe keine
ahnung ob ich daran die rechte hat kann
also zu ihr hin laufen sodass den zombie
wird dann laufe ich vor ihr weg wieder
und sie muss mein gott da kommt sie okay
sie läuft soll potter save me kate ich
wusste dass ich mich auch geliebt hat
und ich glaube wenn ich nahm sie an
laufe wird sie in zombie und danach ich
hüpfe auf nach oben drückt man nicht auf
space sollen dann höflich über sie
drüber quasi und dann hüpft
ich bin durch die ebene durchgefallen
die köpfe hier wieder hoch zu ihr ziehen
sie somit hier runter und hilfe jetzt
hier über sie so drüber jetzt laufe ich
hierhin um wie jetzt
weil sie mich immer versucht hatte zu
umarmen ich weiß nicht muss ich das
immer übersetzen einige male war das
gefängnis schwer zu erreichen das heißt
ich geh jetzt einfach hierüber zu ihr
jetzt hier
nein genauen sie rein man die hierüber
zitiert so mein gott was mach ich die
heilige scheiße soll jetzt kommt ihm
kommen hier mit runter genau jetzt gehe
ich gott gott gott gott oh mein gott
ein bachelor of arts steht da oben als
text dass sie mag wenn sie vor dem käfig
davon läuft deswegen
glaub ich einfach mal hier kommen
hierhin ich spaß die die markus wurde
aus dem käfig auszubrechen
deswegen gehe ich erstmal hier oben hin
lockt sie an höhe und gehe rein um mein
gott jetzt haben wir sogar noch so
komische teile die rauf und runter
fahren das heißt ich warte bis der mich
hochfährt springe dann hier rüber
springen hier überholen sie ach sie kann
ja nicht hüpfen erhole sie hier drauf
kommt darauf kollegin kommen hier drauf
comcom hier mein gott jetzt kommen hier
doch einfach drauf man sie gilt
hochgefahren komplett mir runter jetzt
kommt sie mit mein gott du kommst mit
hier lang genau und jetzt kommt sie mit
in dem kate ryan wo wir jeden moment
sind und die textnachricht oben ist
alpha kurs auf das heißt das
missgeschick heißt unfug missstand also
ich mag sie wegen ihren unsinn
jetzt steht ihr dass es dort auch andere
zombies gibt deswegen schaue ich mal
eben ob ich vielleicht erst mal den
grünen hier vorne eben schon rein packe
so jetzt aber mein gott der grüne kommt
leider nicht ein ich will jetzt mal die
pinke einfach und wohl die pinkel in den
cage mit rein und vielleicht ist das
level ja genau
ok als der typ blieb wohl nur die pinke
und nicht die grünen zombies deswegen
sind die grünen zombies nur dazu da um
mich irgendwie zum heiligen fix euch das
jetzt machen
das ist nahezu nicht möglich also ich
kann ja mal probieren wie wie soll es
denn gehen ich probiere mal die grünen
zombies irgendwie zu tun hab mich selbst
getötet ich muss irgendwie die zombies
hier weg kriegen das heißt sie springen
jetzt so ok einer ist weg und der mann
wird zum heiligen vater eine zombie
zweck und der andere ist auch weg so und
jetzt wollte ich nämlich die pinke so
hongkong mit komm mit ok sammeln und die
pinke wieder die pinke kommt jeder lage
dann springe ich über sie drüber und sie
kommt in den
dieses mal sind die tatsächlich immer
mehr von diesen komischen zombie etwas
was soll ich denn mit dir machen
bohrbagger okay wir sind zu dritt auf
der fläche okay okay kommt bitte alle
mal ganz kurz mit
das ist ein ständiges hin und her laufen
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ganz genau was
mir das okay die habe ich schon mal
unten
ich probiere mal einfach die pinkel
jetzt hier aufzuholen
okay okay die pink ist darauf dass lucky
jump wir haben tatsächlich eine pistole
und ich kann ich kann schiessen wie was
ist das denn alter kann ich die klare
irgendwie auch das mädel kommentar ich
bin ein bär und lieb dich so sehr und
will mit dir
kinder machen und ganz viel liebe ok
könnt euch vielleicht noch daran
erinnern wo ich vorhin meinte dass es
viele zombies sind
schaut euch vielleicht mal das jetzt an
ich glaube das sind tatsächlich auch
sehr viele zombies gerade hole mir
erstmal die knarre die dort hinten liegt
und jetzt hier beim ok der erste ist tot
und zack
bamm bamm bamm da haben wir die drei
tore acht mann jetzt kommt die pga und
tötet mich du liebst nicht wie du tötest
du mich denn ab die knarre holen zeigt
den ersten töten sagt hierunter wieder
und zack zack zwei schüsse dann nehmen
wir die rottmann das ist doch total
schwer jetzt überlege ich mal also ich
muss auf jeden fall erstmal hier runter
springen so dass ich dann den grünen
ok ok churchill cicchitto main board
okay ich töte man eben noch die beiden
hier vorne sondern habe ich dir auf
jeden fall schon mal tot jetzt habe ich
dich hier noch tot und den dahinten der
es auch tut das heißt ich habe alle
grünen zombies tot jetzt kann ich
natürlich die pinke holen laufe mit ihr
herunter so sagt komm hier mit lang rhi
und jetzt ab in den cage mit dir und du
fühlst du noch einen schuss ab nothing's
gonna keep me from my girl wir sind
jetzt gerade mack drei deswegen ist
alles ein bisschen gläubig gehalten und
mir wurde gesagt dass die anderen
zombies jetzt auch in mein gott wie so
reagieren die denn wer nicht nur die
pinkler allein irgendwie nur mitnehme
war warum warum wie kann das nicht kann
mich stoppen ich glaube die grünen
zombies reagieren jetzt schon wenn ich
nur die pinke person quasi einfach nur
an berühre und was ich auch irgendwie
vermute ist das wenn ich jetzt die pinke
person mehr hole dass alle wieder
auferstehen
okay das ist zum glück nicht der fall
alle zombies sind tot und die pinke ist
jeden moment ihren tieren cage drin und
wir haben das nächste level geschafft
hieß mal bin ich hier oben und kann
jetzt einfach mal rein 23 44 schüsse ab
vorher dann habe ich die alle jetzt
nämlich die pinke hier wieder mitlaufen
links bis zum rand an geld kommt die hey
komm doch vielleicht megi ist in
gefängnissen maybe der happy for love
sagte mir und jetzt kommt tatsächlich es
kommt noch ein level in der roda teil
schon bei 22 minuten bin werde ich
diesen level nur einen versuch geben und
meine okay okay das war gerade das war
gerade echt richtig knapp ich habe
tatsächlich alle zombies gerade getötet
jetzt nämlich noch eben schnell die
pinke hiermit und laufen mit ihren
diesen
genau jetzt kommt sie am besten mal eben
kurz hier mit runter und ab in den kate
ryan o mein gott sie ist ausgebrochen
ich bin auch ein zombie geworden das war
jetzt das ende von dem spiel das war
tatsächlich das letzte level wo ich
gesagt hab ja das versetzte level was
ich zocke war tatsächlich auch das
letzte level wenn es euch gefallen da
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wir sie nutzen